is there any chance of saving the iran
nuclear deal new negotiations between
the delegation from tehran and world
powers
began in vienna today if you remember
that deal that was signed back in 2015
which is known as the jcpoa it was aimed
to curb iran's nuclear program and to
prevent it from developing nuclear
weapons in return for an easing of
economic sanctions u.s president donald
trump quit the deal three years ago iran
then started enriching uranium beyond
the levels allowed in the original deal
u.s president biden says he wants to
return to that deal
today's talks bring together iran with
germany france britain russia and china
the european countries say iran's latest
demands are unacceptable they're calling
on tehran to bring more realistic
proposals to the table iran says that
western nations have failed to come up
with any constructive proposals
for more we want to bring in trader
parsi he's the executive vice president
of the quincy institute for responsible
statecraft he joins me from washington
d.c it's good to see you again
trinidad the chairman
of the talks today
i'm said that he detected what he called
a renewed sense of purpose at the talks
he's being very generous with his
optimism here isn't he
he has in the past and i think at the
end of the day you d you do need
optimism in order to be able to see this
through uh not in the sense that it
would lead to any naivete but you need
to have people at the table that
understand the absolute necessity
of succeeding diplomatically which means
that you keep on trying you keep on
trying because the alternative is so bad
but yeah i do believe that his optimism
or or his uh renewed sense of purpose is
justified because at the end of the day
i do think that there has been some
shifts uh uh in the iranian position
that opens up some more space and
enables these talks to continue but
there also needs to be shifts on the
western side so ultimately we will not
see an agreement on less both sides so
greater flexibility and creativity
all right well you say shifts i want to
be clear here about expectations iran is
not willing to return to the old deal i
mean they've already enriched uranium
they have no plans to go back do they
actually that's not correct the iranians
are in the deal it's the united states
that left the deal the iranians are
inside the deal they're not living up to
all of the obligations of the deal
and they're using a paragraph within the
deal that says that if one side is not
performing other side can also then
reduce their obligations that paragraph
is not interpreted the same way by the
europeans but anyway the point being
they're inside the deal the u.s are the
ones that are outside but the iranians
need to go back to full compliance
i'm not seeing any indications that
they're not willing to do so i think
from there and the problem is that the
sanctions relief from the u.s side is
too unstable and too uncertain even if
the deal were to be lifted today
according to a former
french ambassador european companies
would not go back into the iranian
market because what they're looking to
see is who will win the presidency in
2025. they're not in the mood of going
back into iran and they get kicked out
again in 2025. that creates a major
problem because that means that the
economic benefit that the iranians are
looking for may not be coming until
three years from now
we know that the united states plans to
send a delegation this coming weekend is
that is that going to achieve anything i
mean the iranians they they don't want
to talk directly with the americans do
they
no and that's a very very big problem i
think a lot of these different things at
least could be proceeding faster if the
iranians agreed to talk directly to the
united states and i i hope the iranians
themselves recognize that that was a
mistake not to do it but it is important
for the united states to be there
because if there are developments uh
between the europeans and the iranians
that uh
the united states needs to react to it i
mean the europeans are essentially
acting as a an intermediary between the
u.s and iran so it's very important for
the u.s team to be there as well
i mean we know that the talks in vienna
are not the only game going on
the u.s and the israeli defense chiefs
they have also been talking what
messages are they sending
uh the wrong message in my view uh
they're sending the message or they're
trying to send the message that the
united states believes that there is a
military option and if the iranians are
not doing what the u.s asked them to do
at the negotiating table the united
states will shift towards a military
approach i think that is an absolute
mistake we've gone through this many
times before those type of threats are
as ineffective on the iranians as the
iranian escalation is ineffective on the
united states we should not be in that
territory at all we should be focusing
entirely on making sure that diplomacy
works rather than thinking that coercion
is going to be what is going to break
the deadlock here well we will be
watching these talks very closely
trinidad parsley the institute for
responsible statecraft in washington
trade as always we appreciate your time
and your insights thank you